hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in round
four of our coverage of the 2016
Sinquefield Cup yesterday in round three
we looked at a niche do you reverse ding
lien in a very exciting match today we
have the last two champions why it's
gonna be played by Levon Aronian
currently the 5th ranked player in the
world and he won last year so he
understands this tournament what it
takes to win so far he has two drawers
and a win so he's looking to have a nice
game with the white pieces his opponent
playing the black piece is currently the
4th ranked player in the world the top
American Fabiano Caruana
who just missed out on getting to the
World Championship at the end of this
year but he is not maybe another year
he'll get that opportunity but two years
ago he won this tournament and he had
one of the greatest performances of all
time if you don't remember we had a
similar field as we have in this
tournament
except we add in Magnus Carlsen so as
you can imagine very tough field and he
won the first seven games at the
tournament just unheard of all the
competitors there said he was playing at
a different level just no one could stop
him he definitely went on to win that
tournament fairly easy so we're going to
get started with Levon Aronian playing
pawn to d4 Knight f6 pond c4 pawn e6 and
Knight f3 pawn down here to c5 pawn III
just seeing what his opponent is
planning on doing upon a6 a knight c3
and then pawn to d5 so this is the
Queen's game of the climb I took a few
variations to get here but this is the
variation in the Queen's game decline
line white continues with pawn takes on
d5 then after the ponder'd captures pawn
to g3 now this isn't usually what you
see in the potage variation usually it's
gonna be the pawn takes on c5 this gives
black an isolated pawn now it does open
up the board for these bishops to just
rain-free really control a lot of the
board can even take right away with
Bishop takes on c5 and control that way
but with this isolated pawn black is
gonna be forced to really put a lot of
his pieces defending this and as we get
into the endgame usually Black has a
tougher time if a lot of the pieces have
come off the board button
then we see a slightly different
variation we see pawn to g3 on the
knight to c6 just getting more piece and
bottom to the action Bishop here to g2
definitely what we expected to see after
pawn to g3 FINCAD I mean this Bishop
here to g2 getting ready to castle on
that the King side Bishop to d6 so many
times we see the pawn already here on d6
said the Bishop's going to come to e7
but much more involved into the action
with this variation getting it here to
d6 in the center now the pawn takes on
c5 and then the bishop takes back on c5
so this kind of I move for white since
he forced his opponent to move his
bishop twice and he does still have this
isolated pawn here on the default so
Levon Aronian
definitely has a nice hold strong start
for white he castles on the Kings side
and then castles on the Kings side
what's interesting though is his
variation after he plays Knight to d4 I
thought he could have played just pawn
to a3 then pushed forward with pawn to
b4 I started to put pressure on his
opponent kick the bishop back here and
just see what happens then you can get
your dark square Bishop to b2 you could
you could get your knight involved into
the action a little bit more get your
rook over here control this open C foul
I thought that would be really really
good making sure that your opponent
still has this isolated pawn he chose a
different route he played Knight to d4
and then after the exchange the pawn
recapture here on d4 and now both sides
have an isolated pawn so not what I was
expecting to see on board but definitely
looks like both sides are prepared for
this they played one of the the fastest
matches ever up into this point from
here the Bishop's gonna come back here
to a7
Bishop to g5 so both sides just
continuing their development Bishop to
e6 so both sides just have their Queen
to get involved and they will complete
development rook to c1 controlling this
open file and then work over here to c8
doing the same thing
why continues Bishop takes on f6 and
then the Queen comes down here to f6
Knight up here d5 at this point we do
have the Queen and the bishop both lying
down on this pawn on d4 so white doesn't
have a lot of good moves to be honest
except to take this pawn right away on
d5 that's what he does after it takes
the bishop takes
the bishop recaptures and then this pawn
is going to fall at some point black
decides to go ahead and first take here
on c1 ouch after the Queen takes a now
pawn to b5 he can still kind of wait
there's no way to really stop the bishop
coming down here to d4 so first starts
out with pawn to b5 pushing a little bit
forward a queen up here to c6 says now's
a good time to go ahead and take that
pawn and then the exchange on board
bishop takes back on f6 so at this point
is they get the Queens off the board it
almost seems like they're playing for
draw they just don't have a ton of
material left unless someone makes a
huge air this is definitely going to be
a draw continues with pawn to b3 if your
opponent has a dark squared Bishop your
plan and all intents and purposes is to
get your pawns on the light squares and
vice versa if your opponent has a light
square Bishop you need to have your
pawns on at the dark square so we see
the row cover here to d8 attacking the
bishop rook here to d1 protecting that
King f8 now that the Queen's are off the
board and you started to get your King
bulb into the action get into the center
really make that a strong piece in your
attack upon to a5 Bishop back here to f3
it does expose the rook but it also is
protecting it at the same time after the
roof come off this looks even more like
a drawn game like King here to e7 upon
up here to a4 and after the pawn takes
we see the pawn red capture these are
gonna just going to be stuck here
neither the bishops can attack their
opponents pawn so Bishop up here to b3
[ __ ] appear to be for outpost but
they're not doing a ton on board King
here to e2 King f8 and then Bishop to c4
and in this position it was a drawing
game and they decided to go ahead and
end it for the day very very fast match
to be honest for those that were
watching it and covering it they were
not trying to get into any tough
positions they weren't thinking about it
there was no really crazy variations
that they could have even gone into they
played a pretty safe opening on both
sides of the board so all is exciting to
watch the two last champions battle out
such a high level play but then we do
have a drawing game and it is a quick
one
that's game four hopefully you guys
enjoyed and have enjoyed watching all
the other rounds thanks for watching
I'll see you in round five